[Applause]
[Music]
the islamic republic of iran
perhaps one of the most unknown
countries in the middle east and also
the
arch enemy of the west a giant with more
than 80 million inhabitants and byland
area one of the 20
largest countries in the world a country
as big as it is surprising in fact it is
possible that by the time you finish
watching this video your image of iran
the land of the ayatollahs will have
changed
forever because although dominated by a
regular elite of clerics and
old-fashioned
radical and fundamentalist jurists the
truth is that beneath the first layer of
power we find a completely
different country both socially and
economically indeed i would go so far as
to say that we're not for the course set
after the islamic revolution of 1979.
today we will be looking at a
superpower an influential wealthy and
developed country that would almost
certainly have been able to leave
neighboring turkey
far behind perhaps it would even have
become a best friend of the west and
therefore the bff of the united states
and the entire region and no
i'm not exaggerating
in 1977 the last let's call it normal
year before the islamic revolution the
iranian economy was 26
larger than turkey's 65 larger than
south korea's and 5.5 times which means
550 percent larger than that of
vietnam's
during the 60s and 70s the country
experienced a great economic boom it
surpassed saudi arabia as an oil
exporter attracted
numerous investments and a lot of
immigration even from europe it became
the first
industrial power in the middle east its
economy diversified and the government
even started the development of a whole
network of nuclear power plants to
supply the country with energy today
however the tables have turned very much
so approximately 40 years after the
islamic revolution the south korean
economy
is four times larger and the turkish
economy almost twice as large
even in per capita terms the vietnamese
economy is already on par with iran's
[Music]
in fact as you can see in this chart the
iranian economy began to collapse when
the unrest that led to the islamic
revolution
broke out and since then the country has
not managed to take off
again
[Music]
and yes things in the shah's era were
not splendid for anyone
especially in terms of freedom and
speech but certainly what came
after was much much worse so why was
this the case and what exactly happened
to suddenly bring the iranian economy to
a screeching halt well you see the
islamic revolution was accompanied by
profound economic reform that wiped out
a good part of the country's existing
private sector back in the time of the
shah who was by the way
a lousy manager the state had a lot of
influence and the model was very
cooperative but still there was a
nascent and
thriving entrepreneurial and industrial
class that was emerging but
of course the revolution was aimed at
among other things getting rid of
everything that smacked of the former
regime so it was obvious that something
drastic
had to be done
that's something turned out to be
massive nationalizations and
expropriations
these operations were carried out by the
new regime of the ayatollahs as a way of
punishing anyone who had done business
with the shah or his inner circle
resulting in a massive flight of capital
and business projects a process that was
reinforced by the bloody war that broke
out on the 22nd of september 1980
between the secular iraq of saddam
hussein and the new religious iran of
the ayatollahs
quite simply iran's fledgling
entrepreneurial class was forced to
leave the country and seek a better
future elsewhere and no
in 40 years of islamist rule iran has
not yet succeeded in creating a new
business and entrepreneurial class
it should also be taken into account
that since the rise of the power of the
ayatollahs iran has been the subject of
economic
sanctions by the united states sanctions
that have increased in recent times due
to iran's nuclear probe
not to mention legal security let's see
who dares to invest where there is no
security other than the opinion of the
ayatollahs and the revolutionary guards
it certainly doesn't seem like the best
idea in the world
to depend on those angry-faced lords who
live in the middle ages well
all of this as you can imagine not only
greatly limits access to international
markets but also makes foreign direct
investments very
scarce in relation to the economic and
demographic size of the country as well
as with respect to the natural resources
that iran has
[Music]
for example the outcome of the latest
sanctions imposed by the united states
has been a drop in iranian gdp of six
percent in 2018 and six point eight
percent in 2019
we'll skip 2020 because obviously the
pandemic has had much more serious
effects to put it in another perspective
though between 2018 and 2019 if we take
into account world economic growth the
sanctions caused iran's economy to
suffer a gap of more than 22
compared to the global economy that is
the distance iran lost the real cost of
the sanctions and let's not forget that
sanctions may be one more reason why
iran
has not taken off but they're certainly
not the main reason the country
is bogged down with problems derived
from bad economic and social policies
policies
have not allowed it to take advantage of
its enormous potential
yes i did say potential because iran has
many of the necessary foundations to
become a prosperous
and advanced country and yes this is
visualpolitik and no
we have not lost our minds want to
discover the other side of iran that is
never talked about of course you do so
check this out
a rarity in the middle east
iran is a country located in the middle
east and surrounded by countries that
are
very different from it on the one hand
there is turkey an emerging sunni power
that is becoming a regional leader and
on the other hand there are countries
like iraq afghanistan and pakistan which
are not exactly the most stable and
secure places in the world
iran is also the largest shiite power in
the islamic world and this is important
as the two main branches of islam
sunni and shia have been at loggerheads
for centuries
and as you can imagine this strongly
influences relations with many of its
neighbours but
wait a minute because all of this is at
the level of the state at the societal
level there is another iran a country as
different as it is unknown in most of
the west
[Music]
although it may be hard to believe at
first glance the islamic republic of
iran a republic that imposes lethal
punishments on homosexuals and women who
have extramarital sex
is a fundamentally secular and
relatively modern society
a far cry from countries like saudi
arabia and not only that it is also a
fairly well educated society with access
to relatively good education and
literacy levels
well above the average for the region 90
of adults can read and write compared to
for the regional average but that is not
the most striking thing the most
surprising thing is that in terms of
education the percentage of the
population with university degrees is
surprisingly high for the economic
status of the country to give you an
idea
every year about 4.5 million iranians
study at university almost 8
of the entire adult population a
percentage equivalent to that of most
developed countries
and i'm sure at this point many of you
are thinking how is this possible in
this islamic republic where women are
supposedly
relegated to the background
[Music]
well in this case and i insist in this
specific case that is nothing more than
a stereotype the truth is that among
those who enter university iranian women
and men
are on par women are even slightly ahead
the problem comes once they want to work
as the employment rate of
college-educated women is
much lower than that of men because of a
huge set of discriminatory laws and
regulations to give you an idea
the imf estimates that if all iranian
women were economically active at the
same level as men the country's gdp
would soar
by more than 40 percent similarly iran
is also one of the countries with the
highest rate of highly skilled
unemployed of course since there are so
many people with tertiary education and
so many economic problems and lack of
investment
it's not so easy to find a job this
explains why between 20 to 45
of iranians with higher education
depending on whether we use the official
statistics or market estimates do not
manage to find a job so in the end
many of them end up emigrating this
represents another important opportunity
cost some
50 billion dollars a year according to
the world bank but wait a moment because
we can still come up with more oddities
for example and now we're getting into
economic issues despite being one of the
countries with the largest oil and gas
reserves
in the world and also being a major
producer iran's economy unlike that of
its neighbours in the persian gulf is
not highly dependent on oil revenues in
other words the situation is different
from that of saudi arabia of kuwait
countries where as soon as the price of
crude oil drops they set off
all the alarms and prepare for a new
crisis
[Music]
in this way and in contrast to the
regional trend the iranian economy is
considered a highly
diversified economy for example the oil
sector accounts for only 18
of the country's gdp compared to the
united arab emirates where it accounts
for around 30
or saudi arabia where it counts for 42
percent of the economy all of this
despite the fact that iran is estimated
to hold 9
of the world's oil reserves and 16 of
the world's gas reserves and
if we look at the structure of iran's
gdp it is much more similar to that of a
developed country than you might think
thus the service sector accounts for 45
of gdp and if we add financial and
professional services that figure
rises to 51 another example is
agriculture it only accounts for 8 of
the economy which although is
much higher than normal in a developed
country is on par with countries an
advanced process
of development
then something that many of you probably
do not know is that iran in addition to
oil and gas is a country very
very rich in minerals and metals in fact
the country has one of the world's
largest reserves of minerals such as
feldspar barrate gypsum fluorite and
iron as well as strategic minerals such
as copper manganese zinc
chrome and gold and pay close attention
to this fact it's estimated that
approximately five percent
yeah five percent of all the world's
metal reserves are located
in iran of course the vast majority of
them are untapped due to lack of
investment and capacity but
having reached this point let's pause
and recap
we find ourselves in a country
tremendously rich in natural resources
with a privileged location a diversified
economy and a young population
relatively secular by regional standards
and
very well educated in other words we
have almost all the basic ingredients
necessary for the republic of iran to
not only be a developed country but also
a prosperous
and wealthy one however that's not the
reality ruled by an elite that behaves
despotically and detests anything that
smacks at the west iran ranks as the
100th country in the world by gdp per
capita in other words despite
all its resources it's on par with
countries such as jamaica
nambia and guyana but stop how about if
we forget just for a moment that the
country is run by monsters and think
about what an iran with a modern
political system would be
linked what could such a country be like
why is it that every time something
seems to change
investors and large multinationals get
excited about this country and their
mouths start to water well
check this out
the great untapped potential
perhaps the area where we can best
visualize iran's problems and harnessing
its potential is in the field of natural
gas
iran has the second largest proven gas
reserves in the world
behind only russia and ahead of qatar
however despite this its market share in
world natural gas exports is barely
one percent let's take a look at
neighbouring qatar for example a country
of barely 300 000 inhabitants whose
surface area is 143 times smaller than
iran's well qatar expects to earn nearly
50 billion dollars a year from the sale
of hydrocarbons especially
natural gas in a very short period of
time thanks to the investments he's
making this alone is equivalent to
practically all of iran's annual exports
and we're pretty much
only talking about gas so if iran were
to make an economic transition capable
of attracting sufficient investment
their annual revenues from the export of
oil
gas and mineral resources alone could
exceed 250 billion dollars per year in a
few years not to mention the enormous
amount of capital and investment that
would flood into the country in a
relatively short time perhaps
a decade iran could multiply its export
figures prior to the latest round of u.s
sanctions by
more than four times and that my friends
is not
all
[Music]
even in terms of renewable energy
exploitation this country is in an
optimal condition not only because 75
of the country is considered suitable
for electricity generation from solar
farms but
also because iran is located in a wind
belt where wind speeds at 40 meters
above sea level exceeds 5 meters per
second on average in at least
25 percent of the country which also
makes it suitable for the exploitation
of wind energy
in other words if the political and
economic model were to change
in a few years iran could be competing
for the top places among the world's
major energy powers iran would have an
abundant supply of both fossil
and very cheap renewable energy and that
believe me is a great competitive
advantage but it doesn't all hinge on
natural resources
thanks to its well-educated and very
very young population
60 of iranians are under 30 years old
the country could enjoy a huge
demographic dividend in other words
all of those investments could come at
the best possible time when the country
has a young
educated population eager to engage in
new business activities and what's more
have you ever noticed the geographical
location of the country
[Music]
iran is literally in the zone that
connects the two greatest globes that
represent the asian market and the
european market a geostrategic point of
immense value both for the transit of
passengers and
goods as well as for production it's no
coincidence that the country plays a key
role in chinese government's belt and
road initiative
[Music]
in a nutshell any country can achieve
growth that is clear but the curious
thing about iran is that it is already
all the necessary ingredients to become
a success story well
all except one or perhaps the most
important the political
and economic model if the islamic
revolution falls once and for all
and iran opens up to the world as the
vast majority of iranians wish
this country could become an economic
star with the capacity to multiply its
economy by three to four times in
relatively few years there are few
places in the world where the cost of a
bad government and a bad system is
as great as it is in iran a country that
already has everything to be a star but
is nevertheless condemned to ostracism
decline and lack of opportunities the
question we can ask ourselves is will we
soon
see real changes in the land that was
once the former persian empire
we see a counter-revolution capable of
putting iran on the road to economic
stardom can
anything be done to accelerate this
change leave your answers for us in the
comments and if you found this video
interesting don't forget to subscribe
and like
visualpolitik all the best and i'll see
you next time and if you want to learn
more about politics and hear
even more of my lovely voice you can
join us at
reconsider media we have a podcast at
reconsider media.com
podcast see you there
[Music]